[MUSIC PLAYING]
For most Android apps,
it's simple to let
services and intents get
handled on the UI thread.
But as you know, that's
not always ideal,
because you want that thread
to be free for rendering work.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And with the help of a
handy intent service class,
getting this work off the
UI thread is a breeze.
But let's recap.
Say you want to
respond to an intent
but know that the work
is going to take a while.
You don't want that work
running on the UI thread,
because it should be busy
doing rendering work.
The solution here is to receive
the intent on the main thread
and then push a work packet
off to some other thread.
And you've got a lot
of options to do this.
For example, AsyncTask
is useful when
the work will result
in a UI update
but doesn't really help you if
your app's in the background,
and there's no UI to service.
A HandlerThread might
be better if the work is
going to take a long time.
But while you're not
receiving intents,
this thread is just sitting
around, taking up resources.
But there's a third
option that makes
things a little easier for you.
IntentServices.
At its core, an
IntentService kind
of a hybrid between a service
class and a HandlerThread.
See it extends the service
class but internally creates
a new HandlerThread which
deals with all of the intents
as they come in.
Basically, it wraps all the
moving of your intent responses
to another thread
on your behalf.
And because IntentServices
are also services,
you get their benefits as well.
Now for example,
you can use alarms
to schedule repeated work to
happen at regular intervals,
like refreshing some social
feed, updating cached images,
or logging analytics.
And of course, there's a
few performance caveats
that you need to be aware of.
Firstly, the HandlerThread
processes work
from a work queue.
This means that
if a task is going
to take a long time to complete,
it will block the other queued
up intents.
Secondly, most of
the time when folks
talk about
IntentServices, they use
some form of broadcast receiver
to communicate results back
to the main thread and
update the UI, which is fine.
But there might be a
more performant way
to do the same thing, because
delivering messages via intents
involves inner
process communication,
and ultimately, talking
to the activity manager.
So you could use local broadcast
manager to avoid that work.
Or you could just use
the runOnUIThread method
after the work is completed
to push a block of work
into the UI threads handler.
Now besides just
being a convenient way
to get intent work
on to a thread,
IntentServices also
has the benefit
of making your app
a little less likely
to be killed by the system.
You have to remember that
applications without foreground
activities are more likely
to be killed than ones that
have a foreground activity.
But when you've got an
IntentService running,
it puts your app in the
middle of these two states,
more killable than an app
with a foreground activity,
but less killable
than a background app
without all those things.
And probably most
important is not
to confuse IntentServices with
other types of threaded helper
classes.
While IntentServices
are pretty powerful,
they aren't a general
purpose threading solution.
So make sure you check out the
other containers to see which
one fits your particular needs.
See, this is what
performance is all about,
understanding the nuances
and caveats to make the best
decisions for your
codebase, which
is why you should check out the
rest of the Android Performance
Patterns videos.
And don't forget
to join the Google
community to ask great questions
to other great developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]